bonsoir bonsoir ça va alors tes passes
étoile avait dégainé sur les shorts
alors jean luc lemoine vous connaissez
le principe car il essuiera les
téléspectateurs aussi ils posent des
questions enfin les gens posent des
questions sur ces gens je réponds aux
questions des gens dans la rue exacte
des questions qui sont posées au hasard
comme ça et les gens se posent et
notamment cette claque qu'il ya deux
questions aujourd'hui
bonjour je m'appelle laetitia j'ai
remarqué que thierry moreau aimé toucher
la main de bertrand chamerois à la fin
de sa rubrique et sa rituelle ou sont
ils juste homosexuels alors si vous
répondez à cette question est oui c'est
une bonne question vous posez là
laetitia que tu perds c'est vrai que les
deux aiment se toucher j'ai mené mon
enquête a priori ça s'arrêterait des
contacts furtif qui ne serait qu'un
rituel entre les deux même si la plupart
du temps il le rate
et comme il ya deux semaines
il est pas bien donc pour se rattraper
bertrand la revenir en arrière qu'il
aurait pas dû
mais pas me laisser
faut arrêter les gars ça sert à rien
votre petit chèque ça va patron du plus
jeune thierry et 2 quand tu est remplacé
par gilles verdez c'est juste humiliant
pour bertrand
ils s'en foutent
là
j'aurai dans la rue ne savais même pas
la moitié d'un regard mais c'est comme
ça au bout de deux ans ça qu'on a tous
nos petites habitudes nos petites manies
gilles verdez par exemple bas lui ce
qu'il aime c'est parler en noir et blanc
c'est à dire que quand tu l'écoutés
l'impression d'être au 19e siècle la
valérie lui parler de son attitude
vis-à-vis de thierry et jean michel
gilles je te prends à témoin s'est
remplie tout ce que ma posture des
partenariats absolument pas ce que soit
8 mans l'opposition est alors d'une part
mais je ne tiens pas compte mais j'ai
défendu en disant que c'était des
rhônalpins bleus c'est pas la pimbêche
ses lapins bleus faut-il une femme
absolue comme valérie pour rester
féminine avec vos conneries tu vois
fautif il des photos comme valérie je
pense qu'ils veulent a [ __ ]
quand tu parles comme ça c'est que tu as
une idée derrière la tête pour les plus
jeunes qui nous regardent ça veut dire
qu'ils aimeraient passer un moment avec
voilà je lui faire embrocher mais ça
peut peut-être marcher avec lui de 2 202
ans voyons voir comment gilles fait avec
enora malagré à enora tuer la cendrillon
des temps modernes temps mes chaussures
sa capture en direct désormais jean-luc
mais il fallait bien de dire moi je dis
mais il est où
et toi tu démarres c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'on est ce que en régie est ce
qu'on peut amener un chien pour ce n'est
pas parce que bon il avait des idées là
c'est la bonne personne et un certain
moment où je serai
c'est un succès la première à voter ce
soir
le jean luc lemoine et mobile est en
tout cas vous avez entendu un cendrillon
des temps modernes pour n aura je pense
qu'ils veulent a [ __ ] aussi sur
l'attaqué pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent ça veut dire faire un brushing
une partie de son corps et je dis je dis
pas qu'ils aient nora ne mérite pas
cette appellation de cendrillon non au
contraire c'est une princesse et n'aura
que messi que comme ses petits camarades
elle a aussi ses rituels regardez c'est
plus
j'adore ça
alors regardez ça je vais essayer
d'aller voir là-bas décollé la fusée ces
princesses mais qui dessine des beats
qu'il regarde son désir c'est ça alors
isabelle voulez vous savez elle est sa
passion c'est quoi c'est la danse et les
chansons là nous recevions jeune
jonathan donc pour faire plaisir à notre
invité pendant une pause pub nous avions
diffusé son tube je me dis que c'est toi
cette chanson
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'à dix jeunes
officiers sait de qui
c'était évidemment c'était pour la
blague ça fait rire jeu jonathan qui
était juste en face de nous par contre
ce que je lis n'a pas entendu c'est la
suite
chantons mail
elle est grave
une gravité génial non
c'est pas le terme que j'aurai choisi
mais à trop bon en tout cas c'est pas
une spécialiste d'al variété française
tourneront plutôt vers de vrais
mélomanes 30e larusso j'adore
être dans détiennent des chaleurs
m
enfin sorti
les bonnes discussions et l'audience
ravec tout lier de voir le score en
direct devant laura garou qui viendra
nous voir
voilà ils vont vous avez également là où
on voulait mettre à côté comme ça vous
pourrez jeter un regard où vous avez
compris un aime ça c'est que elodie
était ado on comprend la nostalgie
jean-michel il avait déjà 30 ans mais
c'est son droit ce qu'ils aiment les
chansons à texte parce que vous avez
entendu c'est ça ce sont préférés de
toute l'histoire de la chanson française
alors pour te faire plaisir un petit
hommage à nora
la belle des champs vague futsal on
salue
merci
une belle histoire si ça fait plaisir
jean michel basquiat dernière si vous
avez regardé c'était mardi gras nous
étions tous déguisés
juste une image pour vous rendiez compte
qu'un sur la droite c'était isabelle
morini-bosc la plus heureuse
je sais pas pour vous mais ils sont tous
cas pas mieux parce que l'autre gérard
louvin et la fondation du 10 sport et
vous en lui que c'est pas mieux mais
c'était isabelle pour ce qui est des
lichens et prend vous parlez pas une
oreille jean-louis vous envoyer des
textos pour l'émission s'envoie des
textos à gérer parce que je vois pas ce
qu elle est habillée comme moi l'autre
jour alors on soit que ça vexe à ce
point info et nora là elle était
déguisée en catwoman précise parce que
ce sont là les tiens c'est pas évident
là ce jour là nous avions également
comme invité benjamin castaldi qui avait
son micro branché bien avant son entrée
sur le plateau ajouté mais ça me
rendrait mais dans cette émission en
raison de combats qui a 18 ans quand ils
ne rendent jamais ces démissions qui ne
rendent jamais et voilà on le comprend
il était il était agacé qu'on vote les
gens créent tomber et c'est ça mais
c'est vrai qu'il a attendu longtemps en
plus il y avait eu la gentillesse de
jouets jeux ont pour se déguisant en jeu
c'est pourquoi parce qu'en fait on avait
najet qui était avec najat belkacem qui
est avec nous et voilà et najat belkacem
et donc on ne pouvait pas parce qu'elle
voulait être seul comme invité tout à
fait ça je ne savais pas ajoutant mais
tout a une explication mais c'est merci
voilà merci merci ca sert aussi à ça
donc benjamin avait joué le jeu en se
déguisant en lui aussi andrew kz1 des
délinquants du film orange mécanique
alors pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu ce
film ça récit très violent où ces
délinquants vont jusqu'au viol je
précise car sinon on pourrait penser que
valérie bénaïm est devenue folle en
parlant à benjamin castaldi
attention voici la méchante de la
semaine
j'ai très peur tu vas bientôt quatre
mois à savoir voilà ce qu'est vraiment
faire un verre
qui font la différence d'âge vous êtes
la pire et d'ailleurs et je vous le dis
valérie bénaïm vous rester parce que je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose sur vous
tout à l'heure sinon vous auriez quitter
l'émission dès ce soir et elle a montré
un retour demain là c'était j'enlève et
la loupiote et/ou ballet passons vite à
une autre question sourire alors bonjour
je m'appelle gilou quand je vois cyril
hanouna
j'ai l'impression qu'il a été créé par
les dieux comment fait-il pour être
aussi brillant et aussi poilus à la fois
je comprends cette question sert gilou
oui c'est assez rare de rencontrer des
gens comme cyril quai camille combal l'a
compris bien avant nous on lui rende
hommage chaque jour mais depuis quelques
temps au gré des interviews tout le
monde s'y est mis
donc avant quand camille était seul au
bar on savait qu'ils étaient fayot mais
maintenant oui messieurs dames c'est si
quelqu'un réussissait lui ravir cette
place si convoitée
alors pour en juger objectivement et
comme cyril aime les classements je
lance donc aujourd'hui le palmarès le
principe est simple
régulièrement nous ferons un point sur
les déclarations des membres de l'équipe
d'en désigner review et nous verrons
bien qui est le plus léger qu plus vous
en rajoutez meilleur et votre classement
tout de suite le premier prime à l'achat
numéro 4 cette semaine thierry moreau
qui donne 80 % du succès de l'émission à
cyril hanouna alors le tuc ne touche pas
à mon poste je pense que d'abord il ya
et je crois qu'à 80% de la halle la
recette qui tient sur les épaules de
cyril plus fort que thierry plus
généreux numéro 3 jean michel maire avec
son morceau
le succès c'est cyril hanouna le succès
c'est tron a tiré notre là il est en
freestyle ils arrivent ils à une aisance
mais qui est absolument ahurissante et
là c'est vraiment pas de la lèche si
c'est de la bonne lèche numéro deux il
n'aura malagré qui réussit à faire des
compliments en faisant une tête
d'enterrement
il est généreux il est drôle il est fou
il est généreux il est drôle il y faut
il et gdf et enfin numéro un valérie
bénaïm qui nous avait déjà régalés avec
son single il ya un avant et un après il
ya eu un avant et un après serré l'anena
très honnêtement de kiel cette semaine
s'est surpassé dans le buzz tv il ya
pour cyril hahn avant à la presse un
garçon qui casse les codes qui ose des
choses qui n'hésite pas
cyril c'est un type incroyable c'est un
bakker incroyable il a compris que dans
tokyo il ya d'autres ayant chaud
le dit pas de gros mots par exemple
essayer de trouver syrie faisant un gros
mot et nous rase toi les couilles des
animateurs moi je vais classé en 2e
catégorie à ceux qui sont capables
d'être debout vous pour animer
l'émission télé puis à ceux qui ne sont
pas capables d'être de mots
et c'est le bateleur les types qui te
vante un frigo alors qu'il fait déjà
moins 15 et voilà et il fait partie de
cette école là
mais tous ont dit on va chanter s'est
passé n'est pas faux et paillage
bien sûr ce soir soit tous les dons
faits des poses photos érotiques
ah d'accord je lui dis tiens on aurait
pu leur montrer du palais des fausses
photos érotiques fait défaut c'est
pourquoi je les ai vus c'est non oui oui
et non
j'ai compris valérie notre premier
numéro un du palmarès est hérité cette
première place car valérie avait l'air
presque fâché quand on sous-entendait
que cyril disais parfois des gros mots
ah ben oui c'est pourquoi ça l'énervé
autant pas parce qu'elle le connaît bien
ouais chéri ne dit pas de gros mots par
exemple essayer de trouver cyril dit un
gros mot
alors ça c'était hors antenne lewis est
un petit fraîcheur à la raison il est
très gentil pas tu casses cyril notre
phare non mais sérieusement nous
espérons tous que vous allez rester
longtemps mais vous êtes parfait mais je
si je peux me permettre un tout petit
conseil
on dormait un peu gore mais un peu car
franchement quand vous présente comme
l'animateur du moment le winner et
qu'après on fait un plan sur votre tête
l'axé sapri 200% sur ce par rapport à
celui au tout début 2008 ou direct 8
vous êtes donc le à l'animateur du
moment est ce que c'est cette revanche
qui nous allume bonjour